my mama loved you so much
and she appreciated your love for her
and i'm sorry that she couldn't hang on
until today
ashley and wynonna judd in tears
honoring their mother naomi just one day
after her death
i'm going to make this fast because my
heart's broken
and
i feel so blessed and it's a very
strange dynamic
to be this broken in this blast the late
singer and her daughter wynonna who make
up the country music duo the judds were
inducted into the country music hall of
fame
[Music]
i didn't prepare anything
tonight because i knew mom would
probably talk the most
[Laughter]
and while wynonna was previously
confirmed to attend the event her sister
ashley also made an appearance to share
her love and support
your esteem for her
and your regard for her
really penetrated her heart
and it was your affection for her that
did keep her going in these last years
and please come see pop so i know that
we're talking a lot about mom tonight as
we should be
our beautiful mother
but i want you to know that you also are
being inducted to the hall of fame
tonight
naomi died on saturday in nashville at
the age of 76
and more at home on that stage than any
place in the world shortly after her
death ashley confirmed the news on
instagram with a statement writing today
we sisters experienced a tragedy we lost
our beautiful mother to the disease of
mental illness
we are shattered we are navigating
profound grief and know that as we loved
her she was loved by her public we are
in unknown territory sometimes i see
myself
as
the embodiment
of mom and winona
because i have a lot of mom's wandering
spirit
and i have a lot of one owner's love for
life following the news of naomi's death
celebrity tributes poured in including
luke bryan and lionel richie who shared
their fondest moments of naomi with e.t
i mean when i was a kid in the mid-80s
i mean the judge were
as big as any
thing on the planet and their their
music spoke
to
um
you know when when you have
guys going around i mean me and my
brother
we would just ride around and listen to
the judge and guys singing
girls music to the top of their lungs
um they just left such an amazing
imprint on music you know the judd
family
has been
very near and dear to me
because when i first got in the business
the hug that i got welcoming me to
the business to the country music world
was that wonderful family i'm just happy
to have known her
she is
she has been my my rock some days when i
was not sure
of what was happening and i i started
talking about my tragedies
and then she said lionel let me tell you
about mine
and i didn't have any more tragedies you
know so think about that you know what i
mean so
you know god god has her now and so
she's in wonderful hands